ja willkommen zum Seminar philosophische
Theorien der Aufklärung ich möchte in
dieser Sendung einen kurzen Einblick
geben eine kurze Einführung in das was
Philosophie der Aufklärung ist
hier gibt es ein schönes Bild und hier
noch mal eine nähere Aufnahme dieses
Bildes wer genau hinschaut sieht es ist
eine Sonne die lacht und die ihre
Strahlen durch die weichenden Wolken
hindurch sendet man könnte es auch so
interpretieren dass die Wolken wirklich
in alle Himmelsrichtungen davon eilen
sich verziehen weil jetzt die Sonne die
hier ganz selbst Wurst lacht in
durchbricht und genau das bedeutet auch
dieser lateinische Titel darüber Luzern
Post nur Villa reddit das sich die das
die Sonne durch die Wolken hindurch
bricht
jetzt möchte ich erstmal die Frage
aufwerfen was eigentlich Aufklärung ist
wir haben schon anhand des Bildes
gesehen Aufklärung ist eine optische und
meteorologische Metapher das heißt ein
Bild ein Gleichnis es geht hier um die
Opposition von Licht versus Dunkelheit
dieses Thema ist noch gar nicht so neu
das gab schon in der Artikel im
Höhlengleichnis im sonnengleichnis von
Platon man kann das auch schon auf diese
aufklärerische Bewegung beziehen den
Ausgang aus der selbstverständlich
Unmöglichkeit der Ausgang aus der Höhle
in der wir nur Schattenbilder sehen hin
an die Oberfläche in zur Sonne also
Aufklärung ist kein Zustand mit dem wir
uns einfach befinden soll ein normativer
Prozess ein disruptiver Prozess eine
Transformation vom bewölkten hinzu
klaren Licht zur Sonne und eine
wir klären jemanden auf oder eine
Gesellschaft eine Gemeinschaft klärt
eine andere Gemeinschaft auf es ist also
eine Praxis ein Prozess da werden
Individuen und kollektive mit
eingebunden ein soziales Phänomen auch
ein geschichtliches Phänomen was ich
über längere Zeit hinweg erstreckt und
ein Ziel verfolgt über die Zeit die
Geschichte hinweg also ein Prozess des
Übergangs und eine dreistellige Relation
erklärt B über C auf
jetzt kann man sich fragen was ist
dasjenige was aufgeklärt wird wer ist es
der aufklärt ein Individuum ein
Kollektiv
werdet aufgeklärt auch an Individuum
oder ein Kollektiv und was war vor der
Aufklärung und wie sieht's aus mit
Selbstbewusstsein hat Aufklärung etwas
damit zu tun dass wir uns unserer
selbstbewusst werden also irgendwas muss
dadurch bewusst werden durch die
Aufklärung was wir davor nicht klar
gesehen haben
ja Aufklärung ist auch ein
interdisziplinäres Phänomen die
Philosophie haben wir schon besprochen
darum soll es in diesem Seminar vor
allem gehen aber auch die
Literaturwissenschaft es gibt eine ganz
große reichhaltige Literatur der
Aufklärung Lessing ist so ein Philosoph
und mit Rat dieses Phänomens
Religionswissenschaft Theologie spielt
eine Rolle Ästhetik Ideengeschichte
Pädagogik Bildungswissenschaft
Aufklärung hat immer ein pädagogischen
tellerpädagogisches Ziel
Medienwissenschaft und Publizistik das
heißt Aufklärung vollzieht sich immer in
bestimmten Medien in einer besonderen
organisierten Form die die
Öffentlichkeit betrifft und so weiter
und so fort das heißt jede Zeit hat auch
ihre Aufklärung und ihre aufgeklärten
aufklärerischen Medien da kommen wir
gleich noch darauf zu sprechen und
Aufklärung ist ein internationales
Phänomen das bedeutet
es findet statt nicht nur in manchen
Nationen sind verschieden Kulturräumen
in Deutschland gibt es eine starke
Tradition in Frankreich mit dem Seattle
lumiere und in England mit dem inlite
mit und diesen Seminar werden wir von
allen drei Traditionen Denker behandeln
ich gebe jetzt mal kurz ein Überblick
über die behandelten Position erst
seine Abhandlung über die Wissenschaften
die Künste von 1750 das war eine Antwort
auf die Preisfrage der Akademie von
Dijon ob die Wiederherstellung der
Wissenschaften und Künste dazu
beigetragen hat die sittens erläutern
und Russo hat diese Frage verneint das
ist das Titelbild dieser preisschritt
dann geben über zu dünne dedero und
seine Enzyklopädie die mehr als 70.000
Artikel umfasst so sieht er aus und das
ist das Titelbild und die Europa nicht
der einzige der an dieser Enzyklopädie
gearbeitet hat sondern Kollege Dalum Bär
hat ebenso dazu beigetragen und diese
Enzyklopädie ist ein ganz interessantes
Phänomen der Aufklärung weil darin
Wissen organisiert vorliegt und ich
vertrete mal die orientierte These dass
die Form die
Organisationsform die öffentliche Form
des Wissens fast wichtiger ist als der
Inhalt dieses Wissens hier sieht man
jetzt einen Wissensbaum der in diese
Entwicklungen die enthalten ist
dann geht es weiter lametri ein radikal
Aufklärer der ein Buch geschrieben hat
mit dem sprechenden Titel der Mensch
eine Maschine das sagt dieses Buch aus
der Mensch ist eine mechanische
Konstruktion er lässt sich dadurch
natürlich auch durch unsere Vernunft
völlig verstehen so sieht das Titelbild
dieser Schrift aus dann gehen wir weiter
zu englischen Aufklärung nachdem wir
jetzt die französische Aufklärung hatten
David Hume der hier an Naturgeschichte
der Religion
verfasst hat über Aberglaube und
Schwärmerei über die Unsterblichkeit der
Seele dann geht es weiter Gotthold ephem
Lessing jetzt sind wir in der deutschen
Aufklärung
die Erziehung des Menschen Geschlechts
hier sieht man mir geht es um
Pädagogik und Bildung und um die
Menschheit schlechthin das geht nicht um
einzelne sondern um die Menschheit nicht
um bestimmte Nationen soziologische
Gruppen das ist wieder hier das
Titelbild 1780 gehen wir weiter
Gottfried Herde auch der befassen sich
mit der Menschheit aber mit der
Geschichte der Menschheit die natürlich
auch aufgeklärt werden muss die
Menschheit im Sinne einer Bildung eines
Bildungsprozesses
dann wollen wir uns mit Moses
nendelssohn befassen der eine Schrift
über die Frage was heißt aufklärend
verfasst hat und zwar hat er geantwortet
auf ein
Desiderat was Johann Friedrich Zöllner
antiologe des späten 18 Jahrhunderts
publik gemacht hat was ist
aufklärungsschritt Zöllner diese Frage
die Beine also wichtig ist als was es
Wahrheit sollte doch wohl beantwortet
werden Ehemann aufzuklären anfingen und
noch habe ich sie nirgends beantwortet
gefunden das hat dieser Herr Zöllner in
der Zeitschrift Berlinische
Monatsschrift im Jahr 1783 gesagt und im
Jahr darauf hat Moses Mendelssohn der
bekannte deutsche Philosoph eine Antwort
auf diese Frage gegeben er war nicht der
einzige derselben Zeitschrift hat im
selben Jahr ein bisschen später Immanuel
Kant auch eine Beantwortung der Frage
was ist Aufklärung verfasst und sie ist
im zwölften Stück der Berlinischen
arbeitsschrift 1784 im Dezember
erschienen
wir gehen weiter zu Christoph Martin
wehland der auch sechs Fragen zur
Aufklärung verfasst hat so sei der gute
Mann aus und wir
befassen uns auch mit Georg Wilhelm
Friedrich Hegel der in seiner
Phänomenologie des Geistes von 187 eine
ganz
enorme differenzierte Theorie der
Bildung entwickelt hat der Bildung des
Geistes der Entwicklung des Geistes auch
der Aufklärung des Geistes man kann
sagen sein abbildungsroman den er hier
verfasst hat in philosophischer
Bildungsroman also sieht das Titelblatt
dieser Schrift aus
wir werden dann ins 20 Jahrhundert gehen
nachdem im 19 Jahrhundert waren und uns
mit Theodor Adorno und Marx Horkheimers
Schrift Dialektik der Aufklärung
befassen die vor dem Hintergrund der
Entwicklung des Zweiten Weltkriegs
verfasst wurde und
das ist das Titelbild der deutschen
Übersetzung die Schrift erschien
ursprünglich 1944 auf englisch
wir werden dann weitergehen zu einem
Zeitgenossen Jürgen Habermas der eine
Theorie des kommunikativen Handels
verfasst hat er ist ein Schüler von oder
er steht in der Tradition dieser
Frankfurter Schule von Adorno und
Horkheimer hat die Theorie
weiterentwickelt und er hat versucht
Aufklärung durch kommunikatives Handeln
also durch die Sprache sprich Akte
Sprachverwendung in unserer Gesellschaft
so bestimmen das ist ein Bild dieses
Bandes im Suhrkamp Verlag erschienen und
wir wollen natürlich auch die
gegenwärtigen Entwicklung der Aufklärung
und der Publizistik der neuen Medien
nicht vergessen wir wollen fragen was
ist digitale Aufklärung dazu betrachten
wir anknüpfend
moderne digitale virtuelle Enzyklopädien
wie zum Beispiel Wikipedia hier sieht
man das Titelbild das Logo wir sind
schon viele Informationen enthalten ist
ein Globus das ist die Enzyklopädie da
steht
Zyklus drin der Kreis ist auch eine
Kugel genau genommen eines Fähre und
dieser Kreis diese Kugel die ist noch
nicht vollständig das sind Puzzleteile
die es noch vervollständigt werden
müssen das ist ein Aspekt es ist eine
kollaborative Enzyklopädie die nicht nur
von verschiedenen wenigen Autoren
verfasst wird wie bei dieser
anziehklopädie und die der Hund der
Lambert sondern das ist ein kollektives
Phänomen was für alle Menschen der
ganzen Welt aller Sprachen frei ist hier
sieht man schon symbolisiert
verschiedene Sprachzeichen das Omega das
W hier ist ein japanisches Zeichen
hier ist ein indisches sanskrit-zeichen
also wirklich die ganze Weltkugel ist ja
auch natürlich abgebildet die
Enzyklopädie wird zum Globus zur
weltglobus ein internationales Phänomen
und es ist ein freies Phänomen das heißt
man kann diese Information kostenlos
abrufen und auch hier steckt wieder der
Gedanke der Demokratisierung der
Aufklärung dahinter ja das ist so
ungefähr das Programm was wir uns
vorgenommen haben ich bedanke mich für
die Aufmerksamkeit und bin gespannt auf
die Diskussion gerne auch dann unten auf
filocast